[Música]
el objeto circular que este hombre acaba
de levantar del suelo es una mina
antitanque puesta en esta carretera
rural de yemen desde principios de abril
hay una tregua en el conflicto entre
Rebelde sutíes y las fuerzas
procubernamentales pero las minas siguen
causando muertes principalmente de
civiles los útiles han recurrido
ampliamente al empleo de estas cargas
explosivas especialmente en las zonas
costeras de aljudaia y thais los
ciudadanos y las ongs están movilizando
para neutralizar estos explosivos
poniendo en peligro sus vidas
también le salió
más claro
y es director del observatorio de minas
de yemen desde los Países Bajos donde
reside el cortina una red de
voluntariados en yemen cuya misión es
identificar e informar de las minas a
los equipos de desminado muchos
ciudadanos han denunciado la presencia
de minas sobre todo en terrenos
agrícolas y en carreteras las familias
desplazadas que intentan regresar a sus
hogares también han denunciado la
existencia de artefactos explosivos
hasta ahora se han retirado más de 6.000
miles antipersonales En diversas
regiones de yemen
[Aplausos]
los útiles también han puesto un gran
número de minas de plástico que
supondrán un peligro permanente ya que
no se oxiden
también han puesto muchas Minas marinas
también han utilizado muchos explosivos
escondidos en objetos inofensivos como
piedras
[Música]
estos explosivos han cobrado muchas
vidas desde la creación del observatorio
en 2019 y hasta principios de agosto
hemos registrado 426 muertes de civiles
entre ellos muchas mujeres y niños
también hay más de 560 heridos
durante la temporada de lluvias las
recientes e intensas precipitaciones han
desplazado las minas hacia zonas
pobladas por lo que la zona minada se ha
ampliado aún más
otro problema es que muchos proyectos
agrícolas están paralizados por la
propagación de las minas
otra dificultad es que las ong
humanitarias que acuden a socorrer a las
poblaciones locales que necesitan mucha
ayuda tienen grandes dificultades para
acceder a ellas ya que algunas
carreteras están cortadas por la
presencia de Minas
rasgos
mamá le firma más
una red de un metro de altura un campo
de 30 metros de largo y 4 jugadores que
se pasan un balón de un lado al otro
compases al ras del suelo esto se llama
es un deporte creado en bobo de un lazo
en burkina faso las reglas son bastante
sencillas un equipo no debe tocar el
balón más de tres veces suman puntos
cuando el adversario no logra devolver
el balón y tocar la red o tirar por
encima de ella hasta que pierdan puntos
la disciplina fue lanzado oficialmente
en marzo 2021 hablamos con su Creador
para quien el rasgol requiere cualidades
deportivas pero también cierta filosofía
para ser un muy buen jugador de rushbull
hay que tener las habilidades necesarias
en el control de la pelota
la precisión en el pase y la calidad de
los tiros
porque hay que golpear la pelota por lo
bajo sin que toque la red también tienen
que tener resistencia porque el ras Bull
se juega en dos tiempos de 25 minutos el
vocabulario utilizado en el reglamento
del Roswell Busca promover la cultura de
urquinafazo
la cancha de Rush se llama San gallaré
que es una palabra en lengua vista en
español significa el claro tenemos el
maga que es el acto de golpear la red
con la pelota maga es una palabra enyula
que se habla en el África occidental
cuando se lanza el balón y este pasa por
encima de la red se comete una falta que
es lony
una palabra en lenguasan como pueden ver
es un deporte de cohesión Social es un
deporte que nos permite transmitir la
imagen de urkina faso a nivel
internacional el rasgol tuvo su primer
gran torneo en julio 2022 en Bubble en
el que participaron 22 equipos y su
Creador dice estar muy satisfecho con el
entusiasmo que la gente demuestra hacia
el joven deporte pero aspira a más
mi sueño es que el rushbull se incluya
en las disciplinas deportivas que se
practican en los Juegos Olímpicos
sería un orgullo presentarle este
deporte al mundo en los Juegos Olímpicos
de 2024
pasará la historia de los Juegos
Olímpicos si el rasgol se presenta en
Francia por primera vez
sería una verdadera oportunidad para
África de presentar una disciplina
africana en los Juegos Olímpicos
el rasgo se ha expandido los primeros
partidos tuvieron lugar en Costa de
Marfil en septiembre en la ciudad de
Bongo al Oriente de avilla si están
interesados en este deporte y quieren
desarrollarlo en su país no duden en
ponerse en contacto con su fundador a
través de su página de Facebook
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
los observadores por esta emisión
queremos agradecer al restaurante
por prestarnos sus instalaciones para
grabar Este programa recuerde que todos
nuestros contactos aparecen en sus
pantallas hasta una próxima oportunidad